nevada law allows abortion up to the
24th week of pregnancy or if a doctor
determines the mother's life is at risk
the law says abortions performed after
the 24th week must happen at a hospital
it also requires a provider to inform
parents of children under the age of 18
seeking an abortion to be notified
unless a judge determines otherwise
we're just glad that it's official
we appreciate relief with that and now
we can go forward with telling the
people to vote yes on seven the fight
over codifying abortion into state law
began in the 1980s abortion rights
groups collected enough signatures by
1990 to send what was then called
question 7 to the ballot because it
requires a ballot measure i think
that would work to help protect access
dr rebecca gill is an associate
professor of political science at unlv
there is nothing in
this majority opinion that indicates
what the court would do
about a law passed by congress she says
that means the nevada law could be
invalidated or further protected at the
federal level if congress approves it
and the president signs it nevada state
law passed in 1990 says a woman's right
to an abortion is not subject to
legislative amendment or repeal it would
take a signature collection ballot
initiative and a vote in the legislature
to strike it